foreign
women used sexual assault because saying
that I was raped put them in a different
category they felt like it put them in
another category
but what happened to you is rape and
what happened to you it was evil and
wrong
[Music]
what in the world is going on everybody
this is John with the Dr John deloney's
show
a show about everyday people like you
and me trying to do the best we can in a
wild sideways world
when it comes to dating when it comes to
loving when it comes to heartbreak when
it comes to boundaries when it comes to
kids your mental and emotional health
whatever you got going on in your life
this is what this show is for and my
promise is I'm gonna sit with you in the
mess
and we're going to try to figure out
what to do next right and my promise is
I'm gonna tell you the truth and my
promise is I don't know everything I
don't know everything
I will call I will reach out or I will
say I don't know but my promise is
you're not going to be alone as you
figure out what to do next hey it really
is making a powerful powerful difference
um in our show numbers and the people
joining our community so if you're new
to this show I'm so glad you're here
just taking a quick second to like or
subscribe to the show if you're watching
this on YouTube
please just hit the Subscribe button
just click it and it man it makes such a
difference kicking it up in the
algorithms and um if you will take the
time to leave a five-star review it all
makes a difference just a few seconds
doesn't cost you anything to really help
shoot this show out into the
stratosphere so grateful I'm so grateful
all right let's go out to uh Jenny in
Chicago what's up Jenny
Jenna hi what's up hello hello hi I'm so
nervous oh hi all right let's do this
let's sing our let's sing our favorite
song you go first go
I'm just kidding you don't have to sing
you don't have to sing nothing nothing
to be nervous about okay what's up
all right
I wanted to know how I could talk to my
son about his biological father
I guess backstory is I was sexually
assaulted about five years ago and from
that I became a parent to an awesome
four-year-old I met someone
about three years ago and now we're
basically married we have a home
together we have another child together
my parents step my partner stepped into
the father role and although we used a
nickname for him instead of of dad like
when we had our next kid it kind of just
turned into him calling him dad like 24
7. um now my child is four and he's kind
of wondering why his why his hair
doesn't look like our hair because his
hair is lighter and I'm kind of worried
about questions that he's going to ask I
want to be honest with him I don't want
him to grow up and have me break it to
him and he feels like his whole life is
alive but I don't know how to correct
him um at this young age and I don't
want him looking for a biological father
when he's older
um
I don't want him to know the way he was
conceived he will
he will
um
wow there's a lot here
one of the core premises of this show is
that I want us to call a spade a spade
and I want us to all tell the truth all
the time
I also know that sometimes that's that's
um
borderline unethical because
normally it takes some time with
somebody who's hurting who's experienced
as much hurt as you have to establish
the level of trust necessary to get to
the place where I can say hey can we
just call this what it is
but because of this format everything's
compressed and so can I say some pretty
harsh things real direct that um I want
you to know is it's me with you okay but
but for the sake of people listening
um
even just out of the gate you chose some
language that that was very instructive
for me and I just want to point that out
to everybody listening is that okay
yes
often
in my whole career has been a big chunk
of my career was sitting with
um sexual assault victims okay
and with rape victims
and often I found not often but a a
heartbreaking amount of times women used
sexual assault because saying that I was
raped put them in a different category
they felt like it put them in another
category
um
but what happened to you is rape and
what happened to you it was evil and
wrong right
can I tell you I'm so sorry
I mean it's
it's to to say it that way just because
something so great came from it right
like my my child came from from what
happened so I'm so grateful and I guess
maybe sometimes I don't put the real
heavy weight on it and my partner says
I'm guilty of like talking about things
very factually things that have happened
to me yeah there is there isn't there's
a defense mechanism right that I'm going
to talk about everything very clinically
and very distant so it doesn't affect me
I want to assure you beyond a shadow of
a doubt you're being affected
one of the core tenants
um in fact when this show when we're
done I'm going to send you a copy um
it's not out in the marketplace yet but
as soon as it gets out I'm going to send
a copy of my brand new book
um but
stage one of this wheel right this wheel
of being well is you have to own reality
and by minimizing one side of the
teeter-totter that is this experience
you were
had everything stolen from you
you were raped
that's one side of the teeter-totter
the other side of the teeter-totter is
you got the greatest gift of your life
this beautiful little boy
both of those things are your life
experience and they're both true in
squashing either one of them minimizing
either one of them your body pays the
price
see what I'm saying
yes I do
I'm so sorry to happen
it's so so so sorry that happened
okay when it comes to little boy
um
did or let me say it is is bio Dad is he
in jail what's his what's his story
uh he is in the military so he's far
away from here and he actually doesn't
even know that my son exists
oh
that can't go on for very long
and you know that right
yes
um
did you choose to did you choose to not
make police reports or anything like
that
uh I mean I reported it within within
the military but that's
a different way of handling it I
understand
um my I myself was in the military at
the time so that was seemed to be the
easiest like Avenue to go through I
think you may be setting yourself up for
a major mess
if bio dad finds out X number of years
later that he has a child
um
man
let me ask you this hard question what's
the end game here
I uh you know obviously want to be
honest with my child that is the most
important thing I don't want to be too
honest
um
so let me let me the truth will emerge
the truth will come out at some point
you are correct in not wanting your
child to find out the truth and then
find out that level of pain and hurt
and also find out mom lied to me
because in his entire world is in
shatters not just part of it
I don't think he has to learn the depths
of the
um
the depths of the crime committed
against his mom
but also it's not true to say your daddy
just left you because Daddy doesn't know
you exist and he may come back and try
to be the greatest father that ever
lived
and I would suggest that it's the court
of law
and I know you've been through it with
the military court and I know that's
such a zoo and I'm it's it's it's it's
it's
heartbreak on top of heartbreak it's
it's trauma on top of trauma
um when you get tribunal then nobody
believes you or they tell you oh we just
don't have like whatever he said she
whatever thing they're going to tell you
to make this thing go away
um
but you don't want to become a monster
in the process of trying to stay away
from a monster and not letting somebody
know they have a child
puts you in
not great company right now see what I'm
saying
yes okay
I do um and I know it's not what you're
calling but here's ultimately the thing
the story if Dad says I don't want
anything to do with this you take my
name off the birth certificate he's
getting adopted by this new guy fine
he does that
then there is a plausible conversation
to have with your kid
yeah Mommy
um
that your daddy is
somewhere else he's in the military
why did daddy leave Daddy's was working
I mean we're gonna slowly have this
conversation over
um the course of X number of years and
as he grows up he's going to get a
little bit more a little bit more a
little bit more
but you don't want to be in the position
of lying to him and saying your daddy
left you your real dad left you your
real day doesn't exist or this is your
real dad this is your real dad and then
when the truth comes out when he does 23
and me when he turns 18 which he will
right or he'll be in some biology class
101 and a part of the assignment will be
that every student has to do 23 of me
like it will come out especially with
technology the way it is
and so
a phrase I want you to keep in your
heart is secrets
destroy families
and so the the another layer of
complexity here has to be at some point
biodad has to know there's a child
involved
and
if he says hopefully he won't says why
didn't you tell me you can say you know
exactly what I didn't tell you
and you can send a formal request from
an attorney that says you have a son
this guy wants to adopt your son
and go from there that can happen too
okay
thank you does that make that make sense
tell me what you're feeling is that just
awful that I ruin everything
ah
I interact with him I mean but I do
understand that um putting things in
place legally instead of just
like just putting it down on paper is
definitely like a way to protect myself
in the future here's what you don't want
to have happen Okay coming back you
don't want to have a civil and or
Criminal suit filed against you that
said this woman made up charges against
me that by the way were found not guilty
in a military Court
and she hid my child from me for three
years for five years for 10 years for 18
years
she stole those years with my child away
from me
and you will have no recourse
okay
I don't want you to find yourself in
that position when he comes in and says
I want a hundred percent custody I found
out I've got a child that she was hiding
from me she's already leveraged false
allegations against me that was found
not guilty you see what I'm saying like
all all the decks gonna be stacked
against you
and I don't want that to happen I'd much
rather you have an IT the best you can
an amicable interaction if you reached
out to this dude or if your attorney
reached out to him
um did you have any sort of previous
relationship with him or was this like a
uh an out of the blue raping assault
tell me about it
I I did have a relationship with this
person so I mean I had information like
let's say like a phone number or like I
know his Facebook or whatever obviously
without friends or anything but um I
have those like information if I needed
to reach out or if I had like legal
reach out if legal reached out or and
said you have a son via
Ginny and
uh here is the this person wants to
adopt this child
what would happen
I I really don't know
I think that has to be your direction
that has to be what you all decide to do
okay because I again I have
unfortunately sat with kids
who were told this guy is your dad or
this person's your mom they find out
when they're a sophomore in college that
that's not true
and I've had them sit in my office
across from me and they can't breathe
because everything they know is a lie
and at 18 19 21 24
there's those there's that anchoring in
that when all else gets sideways I trust
her I trust him
and if that goes away it's so that's why
divorce is is
so much it's like compound interest it
grows in how much it hurts kids because
they're in what they anchored into
doesn't exist anymore so it's like
cutting the string on a balloon they
just float up in the sky and some of
them make it some of them do great some
of them get tethered again it's awesome
many many
float around for years and years and
years and years and years
so I tell you that to tell you like
man the fastest path towards I I don't
want to engage with this dude I don't
want to have a conversation with this
guy we may we have a kid together
support him important me
when it comes to the moment let me
answer this one question when it comes
to the moment if you ever feel I need to
tell him
there was rape and sexual assault
involved in this
in this one evening this one event that
led to me getting pregnant with you
I would strongly strongly recommend
getting with a
counselor that works with teenagers when
you would have that conversation or with
young adults and letting that person
who's trained in how to have those
conversation conversations lead that
conversation
okay there's people who are very gifted
and they create relationship and they
create what they're doing is they create
new things to Anchor into so that when
they pull the plug on what was
that kid's just not again cutting the
string and just floating off into space
they're very very talented at what they
do
um my one of my closest buddies
um she's Dr Lynn Jennings she'll sit
with a kid whose dad maybe murder
somebody or is in jail
and she will build a relationship and a
rapport with this kid over time and then
say that is here and then it gets a
little bit daddy hurts somebody really
bad and then a little while later it is
daddy took somebody's life
I want you to remember this too this is
really important
kids
understand that half of them is Mom and
half of them is Dad wherever mom and
wherever dad happens to be
right so if Dad's a monster the
instantaneous response as well I've got
that and I'm part monster too
and that's really tough for a kid
you can tell them you are not your dad
you would you're nothing like that you
would never do that
um that's where child counselor is
really really helpful
on the day-to-day with him just being
only four like do I even say anything at
all or four is power four is really
young four is really young okay
um
but it goes real fast four becomes five
and six and seven very very fast
four is why does my hair look like this
and all y'all's hair look like that
you say well let's draw a picture of it
I like your in in and you can begin to
take ownership you can teach this kid to
take ownership of how he looks how
beautiful he is how cool his hair is you
could teach him how to take ownership
without answering any questions
and then you could say like well let's
look at our feet let's see how our feet
look right so we're gonna anchor into
some concrete truths but we're not gonna
say
you've got another dad somewhere here's
why because that Dad doesn't know he
exists and you want to be able to say
um after you've communicated with Dad
either through legal means through an
attorney or directly you make a phone
call
um
you want to be able to communicate and
say Here's how your dad responded when
he found you're alive and I'll tell you
it will be hell on Earth
to have to hold in one hand what that
man did to you
and in the other hand
have that guy two rows over at a school
play five years from now
or that guy turns out to want to be the
best dad that ever existed
and rolls out of his appointment in the
military and gets into something else
where he can be closer and wants to be
plugged in with the life of his son all
those things it's a very real
possibility
your pain and your hurt
cannot bleed over into
punishing your son for what his dad did
see what I'm saying
yeah and that's it
God Almighty that's a a gross
awful mess
I'm just sitting here and I wish I could
hug you I know you're not here
I'm sorry
does it feel like a lot
foreign
we've talked about having my partner
adopt
um my son for a while actually so it's I
knew it was kind of coming out of me I
don't exactly know the formalized
process but I knew it was going to have
to come back in my face at some point I
don't know the laws of Illinois
I do not believe that it's legal
anywhere
to not tell somebody that they have a
child
and to legally adopt that child out to
somebody else without giving notice
I might I might be way wrong on that but
I don't think I am
if there's some absenteeism if somebody
bails takes off
my understanding is there's a there's a
formal process to say Dad disappeared
my guess is you probably signed some
papers that said dad was absentee is
that right
uh yeah yeah
that might get you into trouble down the
road
because Dad may not have been absentee I
didn't know
mm-hmm
and I want you to know I totally
understand 100 agree with why you did
what you did
I don't think you're a terrible person I
think you were doing exactly what a
rational person would do and say I don't
want a monster in my life I don't want a
monster around this new baby I don't
want a monster around at all
but I don't want you to break the law in
the process
okay
all right
thank you listen call me anytime Jenny
I'm gonna be sick to my heart with you
and for you
um yeah call me anytime if your new
husband wants to call have him holler at
me
um
I'd recommend like honestly if I'm you I
would hang up the phone here and I would
call a friend who's an attorney
and walk them through
what you've done what you've signed
where things have been and get their
wisdom and advice on where to go next
really
make no mistake the truth will emerge
someday
all of it all of it
and let's be on the right side of being
people of Integrity even when it's
blindingly hard like the situation
you don't want that that kid who's now a
young adult to look at you and go you
too
we don't want that
thank you for being a great mom Jenny
[Music]
call anytime we'll be right back
good folks slowing down is a critical
aspect of mental health calming music
prayers meditation they're all great
ways to find peace and hallow makes it
easy to start a daily practice of
meditation hallow is the number one
Prayer app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to journaling Hollow makes it
easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com deloney today to get three
months of hollow for free
hello.com deloney
all right we're back let's run out to
Saint Louis Missouri and talk to the one
and only Jessica what's up Jessica
hi thanks for taking my call of course
what's up appreciate it
um my question is
um how do I navigate feeling guilty when
my mom's trying to give me money
um and I feel like it will add to her
financial burden
can you just say no
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
do me a favor can you talk directly in
your phone
oh much much better perfect yeah all
right so
we've been working on
um getting a down payment for a house
and my mom recently inherited some money
and so I would assume that that's where
the money kind of the conversation kind
of came into play
and she said that she wants to help
contribute
um to our mortgage I'm just really
worried about my mom and I don't know
the whole picture of like her financial
situation but from what I do know um she
just took out a second HELOC
um has credit cards that um and is that
retirement age and doesn't have a
retirement and so if I if I were you I
would tell my mom
um
like I I got offers from people that I
care about to help with a down payment
of my first house and my answer even
then was no thank you
um I was super Blown Away by the offer
no that's not true the very very first
house I did I borrowed money I bought a
little bit of money and
it was not wise or smart it was really
not wise
the next time I got an offer from
several people that I care about and I
said no thank you
I never want to live under that again I
would if I were you sit down with my mom
and say mom the greatest gift you could
give me and my new husband in our house
is for you to not owe anybody any money
and for you to be safe and whole
would you be willing to
go through kind of your situation and
I'm happy to help in any way I can we
can apply this money but the greatest
gift you could give me is for you to be
safe
that's what I would say oh Jessica I'm
fine things are fine and we're gonna be
good well that's great I I we are we are
great and we are good and I am so
grateful that you want to contribute but
we're good
so I
have the conversation of like sharing my
concerns
um and the way that she approached it is
that this is
so her exact words were like this is
your inheritance of after I'm gone and
so I want to apply this to you for as a
gift so that I can see you guys enjoy it
um and have like a you know have
Financial stability in a house
and so I feel like I would be like
rejecting my mom in that if I say
no but I just feel like either way I
feel really guilty
yeah
I'm more I'm less worried about her the
gift I mean she's an adult she can do
what she's gonna do
um I'm more worried about
um the strings that come with this kind
of gift
yeah
would there be strings to this kind of
gift
so I have really I don't I don't so kind
of okay
um yeah so I
so we have the conversation or like she
wants to give me this money and I said
um
sorry I said we can talk about that Mom
and and you know like
two children and I want them to we can
start putting that into their college
savings
um or I can put it into an IRA and she
like made it specific to the down
payment of our house or a mortgage
whatever comes at the time and so
I guess those expectations I do feel
like I have good boundaries with my mom
of like this is how far you come
into certain things and so I'm not
really sure I am I I'll just all I can
answer you on this one is
is just
how I would do this in my house and I am
not going to accept a gift that I am
fairly certain or that I know for
certain is going to hurt somebody else
for having given it
okay right
yes Dave Ramsey wants to give me a a big
gift for my house I would probably take
that yeah right if a family member of
mine who I loved who I know is
struggling
um really wanted to give me a gift I
wouldn't be able to enjoy it I wouldn't
be able to sleep at night
yeah I'm trying to think at at worst
case scenario I might accept a gift and
and again I'm just talking out of my
butt right now
um actually I talk out of my butt most
the time on the show but very much right
now I might put it in an account and
never spend it knowing that this money's
gonna go back to taking care of this
person at some point
maybe maybe
um
but and I get the sentiment
I get the sentiment that she wants to
see you guys enjoy this thing
I think that's where the harder
conversation is Mom the greatest
enjoyment we would have is knowing you
didn't owe anybody any money
yeah and then smiling go I don't want to
get a standoff on on you wanting to give
me a gift I'm so grateful
but the greatest gift you can give me is
not my house down payment we're doing
great the greatest gift you can give me
is you don't owe anybody anything ever
yeah okay
and she can write you a check and you
can leave it uncashed she can write you
a check and you can deposit it in an
account with the intent to never spend
it
um but I mean it's not like she's gonna
change check your bank records right
right right
um and by the way if she says no you
can't use it for college funds you can't
use it for any other thing you have to
use it for this
I
I'm not a huge fan of people telling me
what I can and can't do with my life I
don't like that
I like being able to do what I think is
right so anyway that I hope that helps I
I just know how messy those things are
and I'm sorry I wish I could give you
just a clean answer to it but the
cleanest answer I can give you is I'm
not going to let somebody hurt
themselves at my expense
and I don't want someone to use me
to feel better about themselves
like I don't want to be a tool or a
puzzle piece in somebody else's show
like that I don't want to be an actor in
somebody else's play
um
I want someone to want to bless me with
a gift and be able to bless me with a
gift and I want to be able to fully
receive that gift knowing the heart and
soul behind that thing not that
somebody's got some guilt and they
couldn't do something else a long time
ago or they've been struggling so
they're gonna make sure you don't
struggle that's that means you're
getting used for somebody else's
benefits they can feel good and I just
want to participate in that but I know
that's so hard with a mom that loves you
I know it's so so so so hard so I'm
sorry I can't give you like a more like
do this but that's that's the best
that's the best path I could give you
um let me know what you decide to do
because I'm I'm interested in in how
that conversation goes so holler back it
at Jenna um when you get a chance
because I want to know how that
conversation goes and where it heads off
from here but man being able to sit with
you actually do this hang on the line
I'm gonna send you a free one-year
Financial Peace University course my
friend Dave Ramsey
um
maybe you can offer that to your mom
and say Mom we got this for you this is
a gift all the lessons all the all the
courses everything we got this for you
this would be the greatest gift if you
went through this class and you took
this inheritance and you paid off
everything and I had the blessing of
knowing that my mom in her 60s and 70s
into her terminate was gonna be safe no
matter what she's got to be safe that'd
be awesome we'll be right back
all right let's run back to St Louis and
talk to
Christina what's up Christina
Hi how are you partying what about you
I'm doing okay hey this is so far it's
been a show where I really don't have a
great answer for anybody so you may be
number three hopefully I can do better
what's up all right well
um a few years ago my sister was
diagnosed with an aggressive form of
Parkinson's disease oh man what a mess I
hate that yeah now she's in her early
50s and she walks with a walker and
can't stand up without assistance yeah
and recently she asked me to help her
with some personal things like bathing
and things to kind of take some of the
pressure off of her husband
and
um she told me that
she didn't think that she had much
longer
and because all of her efforts towards
treatments have had little effect in
slowing the disease
and I just need to know how I can best
help her through this disease knowing
that it'll eventually take her life yeah
and you know I don't want to think about
her dying yet she faces it all the time
and her husband can't talk about it he
breaks down
and so she needs me and I need to know
how best to help her
just what you you just called it out
um
somebody has to sit with her
who can
call reality reality and live out of
that
not just numb out and pretend
everything's gonna go on just the way
things are forever
I'm I'm I'm
heartbroken for the whole family I mean
it's just geez but there needs to be a
I wish I had another word for this there
needs to be a Reckoning with her husband
needs to be an ability for you here's
because here's the deal on the other
side of truth-telling
on the other side of true telling can I
tell you like my one of my oldest best
friends on the planet who's a paraplegic
on the other side of we just call it
spade a spade
we laugh a lot
and we're sad a lot but we laugh a lot
and we figure out how to get that guy in
his chair and get him to our restaurant
we've gone to concerts to go into the
Guns and Roses reunion show went to the
poison show I mean we go to show I mean
figure it out but that can only happen
on the other side of
now we're calling a spade a spade
everything's different yeah
yeah right and so I I if I'm you
um I would ask her permission to go out
for coffee or something like that a
place where she felt comfortable
and just say I'm feeling a need to
just talk openly in reality wise and I
want to make sure that's okay with you
because at some point you're gonna have
to talk about what you want her funeral
to look like
and what does she want
um does she have a will
and does she have a DNR and she have all
of those things those can be holy
and people can think I'm crazy they can
be hilarious conversations
and heartbreaking conversations all
rolled into one
but they're coming from a place of
choosing reality and owning it moving
forward in that way
yeah yeah you know what I mean
yeah
because here's the deal she knows
she does she knows she's an RN she's
been a nurse for 25 years she knows
and if you asked her
how much do you want to talk about this
I would love to talk to you about end
end times
what you want the next two months six
months five years of your life to look
like and by the way it is not uncommon
for people facing a terminal diagnostic
to say things like I don't think I'm
long for this world and what they're
trying to do is speak into existence I
want this to stop now
yeah I can see that in her okay she's
getting tired because everything
I heard right now that's right she's
getting exhausted she doesn't she's
watching her husband fall apart she's
watching her sister well up with tears
like she's a caring person she's an RN
she doesn't want people to hurt around
her she's tired of hurting she's
exhausted and so it's almost this
prophetic I want this to stop so I'm
gonna start saying it out loud that does
not mean it's gonna stop
okay it could be a long long time but I
think having the conversation about
skilled nursing and
when like give her some options into do
you ever want to go to a home or when
you when me and husband can't take care
of the care anymore what do you want
that to look like can y'all afford that
what is that like somebody's got to have
those conversations and she's in a spot
now where it's getting harder and harder
but she can still have those
conversations just need somebody to
um adult up and do it
yeah
and my promise is entering into that
storm
will be so uncomfortable and when she
passes you it will it will give you
oxygen to know
how intimate and vulnerable and
connected y'all were in the last two
months or ten years of her life
yeah
um
it's I she's always been there for me
I was like chronically ill as a child
and all of the stuff I went through is
what inspired her to be a nurse and I
want to be there for her have you told
her that exact thing right there
yeah okay
we're pretty close
but not quite everything
exactly exactly
no but
um our son's getting married in a couple
of months and she recently asked me to
be like a mother to him during his
wedding and the reception everything
because she can't move around and do the
things that she wants to do
beautiful let her inform that
okay so when she said that she had a
very clear picture in her head take her
out to coffee
and
ask her tell me exactly what you want me
to do I'm I'm going to be there for you
we're doing okay
um and while we're here we gotta talk
will
and we gotta talk your knuckleheaded
crybaby husband he's got to talk and you
know y'all you just gotta go there
yeah and at some point you might have to
sit down with brother-in-law and say I
need you to grow up and we have to have
some hard conversations you can't just
fold out all the time on this
and I say grow up in an I'm sounding
kind of ugly this isn't the season for
healing but he's got work to do
yeah right there will be a time to be
devastated can't breathe lost everything
whole world shattered totally get that
but right now he's got a job to do and
that's to care for his dying wife
to make sure that all the nuts and bolts
are are and and teaser acrossed and eyes
are dotted he's got to do that man
he can't just say like nope not talking
about a kid talking about I can't talk
about it you can't do that and if he if
he just can't physically then he needs
to go talk to somebody ASAP so he can
get some skills real quick
because he I promise you after she's
gone and he looks back and says I just
netflixed and numbed out the last three
years of her life dude that will haunt
him for eternity
he's got to plug in
but sometimes in his defense sometimes
people don't know what plug-in means and
that's where you might be a gift to him
to be able to say this weekend I'm
coming over we're talking about a will
we're talking about the funeral we're
talking about the wedding
do what you got to do but we're having
that conversation
and give him some guided Direction on
here's the things that have to happen
but I love the idea of you sitting with
your sister and saying we talk about it
almost everything
and from this point forward we're going
to talk about everything
yeah
well she's actually the one
I've tried to talk to my husband about
it and
he he just he sobs so she's like and I
told her I said well I you were always
there for me I will be here for you
through anything beautiful
now what she's done is she's been very
vulnerable and she said
um
are you still going to love me even
though it's about to get real real hard
and you say yes
and both of y'all have a different
picture of what that looks like
and so I want you all to clarify
together over the next two or three or
five or however many months what that
looks like
okay okay
what is your expectations about her
funeral what is her expectations about
um Extended Care what's her expectations
about skilled nursing or going to a home
what are her expectations all the way
through
okay okay and I'm telling you the more
you can interject silliness or an old
story or
just no words at all and just grab her
hand
these These are the moments of life
it does the soil doesn't get richer than
this even though it's so painful and so
hard
yeah
and I need you to I need you to hear me
say
most of my career has been spent sitting
with people who reached out and said I
need you and the person said no thank
you or didn't respond
and so the fact that you said I'm in
it's my turn now
I want to tell you man they don't make
sisters like that everywhere I'm really
grateful for you
thank you
that's awesome
let me give you uh two other quick
pieces of just wisdom I've picked up
over the years running my mouth thanks
to people who are either passing or who
are hurting
thing number one is silence is always
better than stupid sayings that are in
pillows
okay
the second thing is almost without fail
people who have cancer people who are
dying people have terminal illnesses get
put in a position to make sure everybody
else in their world is okay and that is
not their job
oh okay so her job is to make you feel
better her job isn't to take care of her
husband her job is to stay as healthy
and well as she can for as long as she
got as long as she's gone
and so when she says no no I'll just
I'll just you smile and go nope nope
yeah
right and she's your sister you can put
it across the room and say if you can go
over there and get it then uh then I'll
sign it all right you could do that
you can have all kinds I mean you can
you can have and she'll she would smile
yeah and say I get to take care of you
now
it's my job
God she's so lucky to have you
I'm blessed to have her through my whole
life she's always been the one to take
care of me her big sister is kind of
like a second mother
for For Better or Worse right yeah
exactly yeah
well do this for me
um
periodically give us an update would you
on how she's doing
okay
um I'd love to see you standing in as uh
at that first dance in your wedding if
you have a picture of that at your
nephew's wedding
okay I would love to see that that'd be
awesome and um
just be fully present in the upcoming
season as hard as it is
I will
be fully present
because these are gonna be
um
the years you look back for the rest of
your life and said I was fully in
it won't stop the hurt the hurt's gonna
be there either way
but you'll be able to sleep knowing I
was there I was fully there
you're a blessing blessing blessing
Christina thank you so much for your
call we'll be right back
hey what's up Dr
dahir check
my new book building a non-anxious life
is now available for pre-order here's
the great news anxiety is not the enemy
we've been led to believe I know this
because I've walked alongside countless
folks over the last two decades and I've
struggled with this too if you create a
life of intentionally living out the six
daily choices I've outlined in this book
you're gonna be able to better respond
to whatever life throws at you you're
going to learn the choices you can make
day by day to create a more peaceful
joyful less chronically stressed
non-anxious life plus when you pre-order
my book I want to give you something to
help you today that's why you'll
instantly get my newest talk smoke fire
and freedom that I gave to several
thousand folks a few months ago where I
break down the misunderstandings and
myths we believe about anxiety how to
reclaim your freedom and how to build a
non-anxious life so pre-order building a
non-interest life today for just 20
bucks at John deloney.com
foreign
we are back we're gonna roll out to the
great Bruno Mars as we wrap up today's
show the song's called count on me and
it goes like this
if you ever find yourself stuck in the
middle of the sea I'll sail the world to
find you
if you ever find yourself lost in the
dark and you can't see I'll be the light
to guide you
we find out what we're made of
when we are called to help our friends
in need
you can count on me like one two three
I'll be there
because that's what friends are supposed
to do
amen amen amen by two words
and I think would heal this world they
are
be there
to show up
love you guys thank you all for showing
up see you soon
[Music]